mit traktor extruder und aromatische
stellt sebastian lege knusprige snacks
im industrie format her
für ihn bedeutet dass mais und aroma
anstatt leckeren erdnüssen und decken
[Musik]
für diese kleinen snacks wie ricky vps
mitgebracht
mit einer snack maschine marke eigenbau
zeigt uns sebastian lege wie der trick
funktioniert
kernstück ist der sogenannte extruder
ursprünglich zur herstellung von
plastikteilen mittag fest mit dieser
konstruktion die eigentlich außer
kunststoffindustrie kommt sauber ich
einen luftig lockeren knusprigen snack
wie die lebensmittelindustrie auch nimmt
sebastian dafür maisgrieß fein
zermahlene maiskörner die füllt er in
dem trichter des extruders und wir
starten die maschinen ersetzt die
zapfwelle des traktors in gang
sie treibt den extruder an snack
produktion marsch es läuft hoffentlich
klappt alles
das ziel knusprige mais max ganz ohne
teig und fritteuse und tatsächlich das
ist das cool
der extruder spuckt luftige flips aus
sebastian muss sie nur noch auf die
gewünschte länge abschneiden
doch wie macht die maschine das vom
trecker angetrieben zermalmt eine
spindel den harten maisgrieß zu einem
feinen brei durch die reibungshitze
verdampft die restfeuchtigkeit im mais
und bildet bläschen der teig prüft
deshalb beim austritt aus dem rohr von
selbst auf
[Musik]
fertig ist der luftig leichte knapper
snack für die industrie ist der extruder
trick lukrativ denn sie erzählt mit
wenig wareneinsatz viel produkt ein
beispiel 500 gramm maisgrieß kosten etwa
17 cent das reicht um fünf große
knuspert hüten zu füllen mit einem
gesamtverkaufspreis von über 4 euro
und nicht nur das mit der gleichen
maschine lassen sich auch andere snacks
wie käse belchen und zwiebelringe
herstellen ohne große umbauten der trick
unterschiedliche dosen am ende der
extruder röhre
sie bestimmen die form der snacks und
die hersteller können sie einfach
austauschen
viele produkte ein trick und häufig auch
die gleiche hauptzutat günstiger
maisgrieß beim geschmack aber sorgt die
industrie für abwechslung
wie das funktioniert zeigt sebastian
lege jetzt
luftig locker und knusprig aber sehr
fahrt weil die sagen verpassen bei den
kleinen jungs noch eine aroma dusche für
das aromabad hat der produktentwickler
eine alte waschmaschinentrommel
umfunktioniert
eine wunderschöne konstruktion
das nennt man in der fachsprache 1 34
kessel
das wird jetzt ein spaß in den kessel
kommen zuerst als aroma träger verwendet
sebastian gefärbtes sonnenblumen auf die
farbe kommt sie auch an wir möchten ja
dass es mindestens genauso aussieht wie
die geschmacksrichtung es vorgibt ich
würde sagen ich nehme ein bisschen
becken 12 tropfen reichen ein bisschen
umrühren bieten eine beliebte
geschmacksrichtung und dank solcher
synthetischer industrie aromen kann sich
sebastian teure naturprodukte sparen
perfekt kann losgehen
damit das öl gleichmäßig auf den schlips
verteilt wird müssen die immer in
bewegung bleiben
per knopfdruck sprüht läge die farb-
aroma- mischung hauchfein in die tonne
durch den schleudergang bekommen die
snacks rund um etwas vom welchen
geschmack abfahrt funktioniert was freu
mich schneller als sebastian und in
riesenmengen produziert die industrie
mit extrudern im xxl-format wenig
wareneinsatz viel output und das in
verschiedenen formen und
geschmacksrichtungen
durch die enorme menge wird der trick
besonders lukrativ
[Musik]
fazit hinter der schier endlosen
vielfalt dem snack regal steckt oft nur
eins aufgeblasener maisgrieß
hinzu kommt auch andere lebensmittel wie
kino hirse und linsen lassen sich
extrudieren und im vergleich zu den
snacks aus maisgrieß noch teurer
verkaufen
das gilt auch für viele cerealien und
süßwaren hier steckt oftmals
explodiertes getreide drin da wir
verbraucher die knusprige konsistenz
mögen greifen wir gerne zu zahlen aber
in diesem fall vor allem für viel los
knusper knusper knochen was sind eure
die brings nix sagt es uns in den
kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips
[Applaus]